Announcer: From the nation's capital, The
American Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
and Research presents "Public Policy Forums,"
a
series of programs featuring the nation's
top authorities presenting their differing
views on the vital issues which confront us.
Today's topic, "Revitalizing America: What
are the Possibilities?"
John: In the classic mythology of old Greece
and Homer, ancient mariners feared twin monsters,
Scylla and Charybdis, rock and whirlpool garbed
in the fantasies of the unknown, in the Straits
of Messina between Sicily and the toe of Italy.
They represented two equally perilous alternatives,
neither of which could be passed without encountering
and probably falling victim to the other.
Mythology deals with the imaginary or fictitious,
with gods and demigods and monsters that dwell
in the mind.
Those who chart the course of the American
ship of state in this new decade do not deal
with inventions of the mind.
The monsters that they must contend with are
real, facts of daily life, and the way ahead,
a tangle of alternatives so complex and dangerous
as to chill the stoutest heart.
A safe course must be plotted in defense,
the economy, foreign affairs, energy, government
regulation, taxes, health, and social and
political processes, and each must succeed
without falling victim to the others.
To examine the course to take us to safe harbor,
the way to a revitalized America, we have
a highly expert panel.
To my far right, Congressman Newt Gingrich,
Republican, member of the House Administration,
Public Works, and Transportation committees.
To my immediate right, Representative Richard
B. Cheney, White House Chief of Staff under
President Ford, the new chairman of the Republican
Policy Committee in the House, and a member
of the Interior and Insular Affairs Committees.
To my immediate left, Representative Richard
A. Gephardt, member of the Ways and Means
and Budget Committees, and appointed Chief
of Task Forces, a new position in Democratic
Party leadership in the house.
And to my far left, Representative Wyche Fowler,
Democrat, a member of the powerful Ways and
Means Committee and the Select Committee on
Intelligence.
Well, to begin, gentlemen, I would pose the
same question to each of you.
What are the most critical policy issues,
the major priorities in public policy?
Representative Cheney.
Representative Cheney: Well, I think, John,
that first and foremost from the standpoint
of the Congress, the issues we're gonna have
to deal with in the months and years ahead
deal very much with the economy.
It seems to me we've reached a point in this
country where the rate of economic growth
is such that we no longer are able to do either
of two very important things.
One, to provide sufficient public revenues
to take care of our public responsibilities,
not only in the domestic area but also in
terms of national defense.
And secondly, we are no longer able, because
of the lack of vitality in our economy, to
provide a real prospect for the American people,
that their lives of their children will be
better than their own.
That they can look forward to a bright and
optimistic future situation of economic prosperity
to come, and we've lost that very, very important
element.
John: Representative Gephardt.
Representative Gephardt: Certainly, one would
have to agree that the economy has to be the
dominant issue.
Upon it depends most everything in our society
and the economy has simply not been working
correctly for the past 8 to 10 years, and
therefore the Congress will be dominated by
that issue.
There are lots of sub issues that relate to
it, energy being the most important, and in
my view we will continue to wrestle with that
problem through the rest of our lifetimes.
John: Representative Gingrich.
Representative Gingrich: I think the two major
issues that are going to affect us in the
whole decade of the '80s are, one, how do
we rebuild a sense of trust and dialogue in
our political structure, so that people have
some sense that how they vote matters and
that what happens in the elected process means
something?
And second, how do we reopen the system to
new ideas?
I think that at every level what we're seeing
are symptoms.
I think that inflation and the decay of productivity
and the decay of our defense structure, the
decay of the bureaucracy, in some ways the
collapse of education are all related to the
fact that we're increasingly muscle-bound
in a system that no longer is open either
to pragmatism or to new ideas.
John: Representative Fowler?
Representative Fowler: Well, I would certainly
agree with the specifics that my colleagues
have just mentioned.
I would also like to tag on to what my Georgia
colleague, Mr. Gingrich, has said.
I think that overarching all of our public
policy decisions is the question of how we
once again ensure accountability, and the
public knows where that accountability lies,
where it runs, so that they feel again that
they are part of the system, in a government
by the governed.
The other footnote to that is not talked about
very much.
I think we will see that equally important
as any congressional decision, that more and
more our lives in this country will be determined,
the quality of our lives in this country will
be determined by the caliber and the quality
of international agreements, equally as much
as domestic legislation, either emanating
from the Congress or from the White House.
John: Right.
The National Academy of Public Administration,
a 29-member panel of former cabinet members,
governors, labor leaders, members of the Congress,
calls for a more strongly united and disciplined
Congress, a greater capacity for coordinated
action by the President and the Congress,
and for a higher level of managerial ability
throughout the government than has been customary.
How say you to those recommendations as a
prescription for the future?
Who would like to start it?
Representative Gephardt: Well, they're good
recommendations.
I think I have greater hope for making the
Congress more willing to take on some of the
unpleasant decisions that I think have to
be made in the next 10 years in order to meet
the problems we've discussed.
I suppose I'm coming out a bit pessimistic
about our ability to achieve much greater
levels of competence and managerial ability
in the United States government, the federal
level.
We do not have a system that is a lot like
the Japanese system, where the best and the
brightest desire public service at the bureaucratic
level.
We tend to not pay wages that are commensurate
with private industry, certainly today with
the levels of inflation.
So therefore I don't foresee a time when our
executive branch, our bureaucracy is going
to be improved a great deal.
Jimmy Carter talked about that a lot.
Most every president talks about it, talks
about reorganization.
We passed a major civil service reform act.
It has yielded some good results, but I think
on the whole we can't see much positive happening.
I have a greater hope that we will have a
Congress that is more accountable, that's
more willing to take on some of the tough
decisions that we have to face.
I think in the past few years, we've seen,
for instance, a budget process which hasn't
yielded a great deal of courage perhaps in
fiscal discipline, but at least we've got
a process in place and hopefully in the years
ahead it will yield that kind of fiscal discipline
that I think is so important.
John: Representative Cheney?
Representative Cheney: Let me differ just
a little bit with Dick.
I think Congress has been a big part of the
problem, I'd have to argue, and that within
recent years power has been diffused within
the body, to the extent that Speaker of the
House, leadership of either party is unable
to deliver.
When a commitment's made to the president,
whatever his party might be, it's almost impossible
to build around a commitment by the leader
the kind of coalition that's required to pass
his program.
I think that one of the fundamental problems
has been the extent to which we placed restraints
on presidential authority over the last several
years.
We've been so consumed with the trauma of
Watergate and Vietnam that every time we've
tampered with the relationship between the
executive branch and the Congress, we've done
so in a way that's designed primarily to avoid
future abuses of power similar to those that
are alleged to have happened in the past.
We've been concerned with the so-called Myth
of the Imperial Presidency.
And I don't think there's any way we can address
the public policy agenda that we all talked
about at the outset unless we really talk
about strong executive leadership, and that
seems to me we've got to restore some balance
between the Congress on one hand and the executive
branch on the other.
John: Representative Gingrich?
Representative Gingrich: If I can dissent
from my good colleague from Wyoming, I think
what we need is a stronger Congress, not a
weaker.
That the greatest danger of the Reagan administration
is that conservatives will decide you can
trust imperial presidents as long as they're
right-wing when they're imperial.
That the great problem has been and will continue
to be that we need a generation of social
invention, that the old system has died, whether
it's the big city machine or the Rayburn Congress,
and that in the age of television and jet
aircraft and computerized letters, we have
not yet invented the working political system
that will govern us for the next half century.
But that system, I think, if we're gonna remain
a free country, will be focused in the House
and the Senate, not in the White House.
And that's one of our major problems is that
for 20 years now, we have focused on the wrong
institution to save this country.
And I think that until we get back to that
and things like the invention of the task
force chairmanship that Dick Gephardt has,
I think are steps towards inventing a more
effective more mobile and more fluid system.
Representative Gephardt: Dick, could I follow
on and ask this?
John: Sure.
Representative Gephardt: It's my sense also
that the Congress needs to do a much better
job of oversight and evaluation.
People have talked for years about sunset
legislation and the Congress doing a better
job of overseeing the implementation of programs
that it's passed.
We aren't doing that yet.
I think we'd all admit that.
We don't know whether that will ever happen,
but don't you agree that that has to happen,
or we simply have to keep bumping along the
way we are.
We can't really, I don't think, today, ask
Congress to authorize giant programs, to appropriate
money for those programs, and then to step
back and hope that the executive branch does
what it wants done, without knowing what's
happening, without asking questions, without
really day-to-day overseeing to a large extent
what is happening.
That doesn't mean they tell them how to run
the department, but it does mean they have
to understand how the law is being implemented
so they can either change the law, or get
rid of it or get rid of the program.
Representative Cheney: I certainly would agree
that we need to do a better job on evaluation
and oversight of the executive branch.
My problem though, and speaking to Newt's
point and follow up on yours too, Dick, you
serve on the Budget Committee.
I think the budget process has become a joke.
We're absolutely as an institution incapable
of making the kinds of decisions that the
budget process seems to warrant.
I don't think the solution is going to be
found in giving Congress a bigger role than
they've had in the past.
It seems to me a proper way to go would be
for Congress to go ahead and set that overall
spending ceiling, but if we're unable to make
the hard decisions on program cuts, let's
delegate the authority to the President to
impound funds within certain broad parameters
that we might establish.
He used to have that authority, it was used
very effectively, until the Nixon administration,
at which time, because of Watergate, Congress
removed that authority from him.
I don't think the Congress is ever going to
have the courage to do anything about the
entitlement programs, but with strong executive
leadership perhaps we can begin to address
that very fundamental issue.
And you can't talk about addressing the budgetary
problems we face and the economic problems
we face unless we really are willing to bite
the bullet on entitlement programs.
Representative Fowler: I think Dick that you'll
agree the problem with the budget process
is that we all vote for the popular programs,
unwilling to stare a veteran in the face and
say, "No, I'm not gonna double you the benefits
for the 10th straight year."
And go ahead and swell it up and then vote
against the final product that we have swelled
by our own hypocrisy.
And I just don't see how turning that back
to the president...First of all, I just don't
think it's possible under this kind of system.
Representative Cheney: Also he's less of a
hypocrite than we sometimes are.
John: Representative Gingrich?
Representative Gingrich: I think the reason
I like the budget system and the fights that
we had in the budget, is that it is the first
real attempt by the house to create a parliamentary
environment in which there is some effort
at some level to say, "Here we stand.
You can measure us on this vote and this has
an aggregate impact on the whole system."
And until you can get to those kind of tough
folks that are an aggregate that you can't
avoid, because unlike Dick, I don't have any
faith in electing presidents who are better
than Congressmen.
I don't think they are better than Congressmen
[inaudible 00:13:45] frankly.
I think it's dangerous to think of presidents
as being more courageous than congressmen.
They just have better speechwriters and better
makeup.
I think that the congressmen collectively
are more accurate reflecting the country,
and what you've got to have in my judgment,
is you've got to have a political system that
holds us accountable.
And at that point I think somebody's going
to have to bite the bullet even if it takes
three or four cycles of defeat to finally
get to a party that's willing to do it.
Representative Cheney: But Newt, on that point
of accountability, you know, the fact of the
matter is there's this enormous dissatisfaction
in the country with government.
You talked about it yourself.
Great frustration with the way things are
going, and yet 96% to 97% of all House members
who run for re-election get reelected.
Representative Gingrich: Not this year.
Representative Cheney: Well, close to it.
Not that far off.
Representative Gingrich: I mean but when [inaudible
00:14:30] loses and [inaudible 00:14:31] loses
and the Senate changes hands...
Representative Cheney: Okay, all right, but
those are because of special situation.
But the basic fundamental long-term average
percentage of House members is well over 90%
who want to get reelected get reelected.
I mean the president of the United States
is the one I think who most accurately reflects
broad fundamental shifts in public opinion.
Representative Gingrich: And is the most dangerous.
Representative Cheney: I think that's the
most [inaudible 00:14:49] Well, but see if,
you can be concerned about danger, but it
seems to me that in times of great national
peril in the past, whether we talk about the
Civil War, or we talk about FDR during the
depression or World War II, we have basically
responded as a society to those crises by
having the president, whoever he was, assume
authority that was extraordinary, and it seems
to me if you're as concerned as I am about
the 1980s, then we're talking about a situation
again when at a minimum, at a minimum, we
have to reduce the trend of the last few years
where we've undermined presidential authority,
rather than granted him additional authority.
Representative Fowler: Dick, I don't want
to, with none of us, I don't think we want
to come back, keep coming back at you as the
point man...
Representative Cheney: That's all right.
Representative Fowler: ...on this.
But I just, I find it...I'm just very surprised
about what you said about the president being
the most sensitive to public opinion.
I mean, the United States Congress...
Representative Cheney: In the broad, broad
national opinion, he's far more close to that
than...
Representative Fowler: But see, he doesn't
even have any way of doing that.
I mean he can walk around with a bunch of
polls that may be outdated a week later, depending
on international events.
But one of the reasons that Jimmy Carter got
beat, I can say this, coming from Georgia,
is that he did not understand that the people
closest to the people in this country, the
elected officials closest to the people, were
the men and women in the United States Congress.
We are the eyes and ears.
We are the ones that are home every weekend.
We are the ones that are on the ground, sitting
and listening to little old ladies telling
how their Social Security check has just been
eaten alive by inflation.
Concerned about immigrants coming into Florida.
Worried about people starving across the ocean,
but also having real conflicts as to well
I [inaudible 00:16:31] spend my money when
I don't have any money to do it.
Representative Cheney: But are we capable
of making...
Representative Fowler: And he did not...
Representative Gephardt: Are we capable of
making policy decisions to do anything about
it?
And the answer obviously is no, we can't even
pass a budget.
Representative Fowler: Well, see I don't...Well
I would, I, whether that's the overall policy
decision is, I think, up to discussion.
But I'm not willing to concede, or we oughta
all go home, that we cannot, along the lines
that Newt was discussing, find a way.
I'll put...I'll give the other side of the
argument, but giving the same thing that Newt
was saying.
Not so much that we have a program that helps
everybody in a certain way.
I think that's one of the problems that we've
gotten into, of parceling out the goodies.
The American people will support a policy,
in my opinion, if they at least know...if
they know it hurts, but if they know that
everybody is getting hurt equally.
That everybody is sacrificing.
That you're not exempted because you live
on this side of the street, or at a certain
income, or have a certain special interest
group working for you.
But where we develop a common goal and say,
"Look, it's gonna hurt.
But if you want to be energy independent,
if you want to get the inflation down, if
you want to get off of these national deficits,
then we all got to sacrifice in some way."
I don't think it needs to be done in the tone
of a national malaise, as the way President
Carter put it.
But, you know, as a Rooseveltian, Wilson,
Teddy Roosevelt, your Roosevelt, not ours,
policy of how we get from here to there and
what we all have got to do to accomplish it.
Representative Gingrich: The problem I would
suggest to Mr. Cheney here and to people who
look to a president is that the central purpose
of politics in a free society is to be an
arena, in which somebody has a vision, which
they communicate well enough that enough different
interests, in Madison's term, that enough
different interests come together to pass
that vision, and that the gravest danger we
face since Franklin Roosevelt is the perennial
pursuit of a personality that can transcend
by management and administration, the political
job of knitting together a majority in the
House and Senate, and knitting together a
majority in the country and preaching a change
that will help enough people, and it can,
you can help them by stopping inflation, or
you can help them by new opportunities.
But what worries me precisely about I think
the mindset of the near future, is the danger
that this administration will decide that
while it's conservative in economic philosophy,
it is in fact radically liberal in a willingness
to accrue power, and I think that strong presidents
are inherently and fundamentally dangerous
to this society, because they short-circuit
the political education of saying, "This is
my vision for the '80s.
This is where we have to go.
This is why I want your vote."
And if we don't do that kind of work in the
House and the Senate, and thereby in the country,
because Wyche is right, we're the ones that
go back, then I think we shouldn't have changes
because it'll undermine the whole fabric of
society.
Representative Gephardt: Let me just trail
onto that a moment.
I think Jimmy Carter's greatest failing with
Congress was his inability to communicate
effectively and consistently, and on a regular
basis with the members of his own party in
the Congress.
I'm new here, I have not seen a lot of congressional
liaison operations.
In my view this was not a good one, because
it did not carry on that kind of consistent
communication.
I'm not saying that if it had been done that
a great majority would have fallen in line
on these tough votes that would have had to
have been taken.
But I agree with Newt that the Congress can
work.
I agree with him that the budget process,
while it has a lot of failings right now,
is a significant step forward, and can really
reach its promise.
But it will take inventive, creative leadership
from the President and a lot of creative leadership
within the Congress, which I think exists
there and can be brought into bloom.
But clearly, it's not there now and maybe
it hasn't been for some time.
John: Let's come down to some of the nuts
and bolts of what you have been putting on
the table here as critical to the formation
of public policy that will give us a more
confident and constructive future.
Among public policy goals which have been
widely discussed are higher defense spending,
lower inflation, and significant tax cuts.
Now can we really achieve any of these goals
in any real near term?
Representative Cheney: I think, John, it's
extremely important when we talk about those
various goals that you have to put them within
some kind of time perspective.
I think we've got to talk in terms of a two
or three or four year period of time, and
the bottom line in my mind is that we are
not gonna be able to meet our defense needs,
and we are not going to be able to meet our
domestic needs, unless we do in fact reinvigorate
the American economy.
Without real economic growth, we simply aren't
going to be able to meet our public policy
obligations, let alone take care of the private
sector, too.
Representative Gephardt: I think you have
to reach priorities, I think that's what Dick
is saying.
I would put the highest priority on controlling
inflation, because I think short of doing
that, everything else falls apart.
I think that takes among other things a restrained
fiscal policy, a creative, effective energy
policy, and a lot of things happening in the
private sector in terms of productivity and
management-labor relations, and a number of
other things that are not happening at this
time.
I think without addressing that problem as
the number one priority, everything else will
fall away.
I think if we can achieve a solution to that
problem, effectively, in the 5 to 10 year
period, which is what I think it will take,
we can then begin to effectively address the
other questions that have been put on the
table.
I think Margaret Thatcher's experience, while
we are not England, is a good thing to look
at in seeing how long it's going to take and
how difficult it will be.
John: [inaudible 00:22:39].
Representative Gingrich: First of all I think
that the major problem in this country economically
is increasing productivity, increasing investment,
increasing new technology.
Because I think if you produce enough things
over time they mop up the extra money.
I think that if you try to control inflation
the way we've tried to for the last 20 years,
it's politically impossible in this society.
You cannot squeeze inflation out of a democracy,
because in the long run, squeezing it out
squeezes the public, the public won't stand
for it, and if the Republican leadership and
the Reagan administration tried to squeeze
inflation out by severe cuts in spending,
or by severe cuts in terms of monetary policy,
what you are going to see I think is a Democratic
landslide in 1982.
It is not possible, as Margaret Thatcher has
proven, to squeeze a free society in two years
severely enough to change the inflation rate.
What you've got to do instead is change the
tax code, encourage businesses to invest in
new computer systems, new productivity systems,
new factories, so that there's enough extra
productivity that you can both buy the defense
we need, and buy the additional homes and
the additional goodies and pay the taxes I
think to at that point balance the budget.
John: Representative Fowler?
Representative Fowler: That's not going to
work.
I say with great respect to my colleague.
One of the problems is, of course, I mean
everybody is for increasing productivity in
certain industries.
I think Dick Gephardt and those of us on Ways
and Means, you will see, targeted tax credits,
exemptions, aids for American industry that
will enable them to compete more effectively.
But the problem with that philosophy is that,
you know, all the world knows how to make
everything that we make now.
Used to be that we could just gear up production
and we could make all these things and nobody
else made them, but everybody the world knows
how to make plastic buckets, and electric
toothbrushes, and color television sets.
And they're making 'em.
And we can produce all we want and find that
there're just not markets for them.
And I of course on the international scene,
part of the balance of payments and the delicacy
of what I mentioned at first of some international
agreements, is a recognition of the fact that
in the production of all these things that
they produce and sell, that they get the foreign
exchange to buy a lot of our excess wheat,
and many of the monies that come back into
our country.
So I would like to think that simply the testing
of that philosophy, you know, if we set the
Keynesians aside, now we're going to go over
and say if we just start producing everything
again, all of a sudden our economy is going
to sing, but I don't see any evidence of that,
though I think that certainly that will be
the direction that this new Congress goes
in.
John: Well economics are known as the dismal
science, but even there nowadays I think you
tend to hear in these problems you find so
critical in the statement of priorities with
which you opened, this question of the economy,
inflation, and the budget.
You find in basic economics they talk about
expectations, inflationary expectations perhaps
more dangerous than any of the specific causes
which bring about inflation, because the public
expects it.
Now does the Congress have the means and the
will to try to persuade the American people
that inflation is going to be brought under
control?
Do you feel that you did it for instance with
respect to energy policy?
How long did it take the American people to
discover we had an energy problem?
And do they have, really understand it yet?
Representative Gingrich: John, the problem
with that whole line of thinking, frankly,
is that we're a free society, and that people
generally speaking are reasonably bright,
and that they look at all the different indicators
and all the different news shows, and all
the different advertising and they make up
their own minds.
And if they look at a country floundering
towards 20% interest rates, they say to themselves,
"Aha, prices are going up."
And they don't care what the Council of Economic
Advisors says, or what the Ways and Means
Committee says, or what the President exhorts
in his latest speech, because they're not
stupid.
And we have had a consistent series of advice
from economists over the years, based on the
assumption that the public is dumber than
they are, which I think given the track record,
is hard to prove.
You know, I think that we would frankly be
better off literally to ignore...and I say
this as a historian, and maybe have a bias
in that sense.
But I think that economics has not only been
the dismal science, it's been the irrelevant
science.
If we went back to the fundamentals, people
produce more when they get more money for
producing it, they produce less when they
get less money for producing it, and just
ignored most of what we've invented with computers
in the last 20 years in economics, this would
be a far healthier country, and we wouldn't
be trying to outguess the American people.
John: Anybody else want to tackle that one?
Representative Fowler: No, I like that.
John: You like that?
All right, let me come back...Yes, sir?
Representative Gephardt: I don't like it.
John: [inaudible 00:27:38] Good, lay it down.
Representative Gephardt: I think he's right
when he says they watch what we do rather
than what we say, or what's happening rather
than what we're saying.
I don't think you can talk people out of an
inflationary psychology.
I think over a 5 or 10 year period you can
convince them that it's not an inflationary
time.
I don't go as far as Newt does on what you
can do on the supply side.
I think it's a good theory.
I think we've been hung up on consumption,
and haven't worried about production for too
long.
I just don't go as far as he does.
I think you have to balance it with concern
about consumption, and concern about your
fiscal policy.
And I just wouldn't get as carried away as
he does and others in his party do about what
you can accomplish on that score.
But I think there's a great deal of truth
in what he's saying.
John: All right, let's come at it from another
direction.
If we redirect a substantial portion of our
resources to national defense, what specific
areas will we redirect these resources away
from?
Representative Gephardt: Well, there's no
magic in the budget.
If you are for a restrained budget which comes
to as close to balance as you can get with
all the things we want to do, there's only
one place to take the money, and that's from
domestic programs, and more specifically it
has to come from some entitlement programs
that Dick talked about.
There are not enough of what we can call controllable,
which is really a misnomer, but everything
is controllable in the budget.
But we have called a series of domestic programs
that are not Social Security or not disability
payments, are not black lung payments and
what have you as "controllable programs."
There are not enough of those in my view to
cut a budget to get near balance.
So you've got to look at Social Security.
You've got to look at disability.
You've got to look at some of the welfare
programs, in addition to health and education
and the other so-called controllable items,
if you're to free up money, significant money,
which I think you have to do for defense.
Representative Cheney: Yeah, I would point
out I guess if, you know, if you go back to
the peacetime fifties when Dwight Eisenhower
was president, or the early years of the Kennedy
administration when we were at peace as a
country, we spent close to 11% of our gross
national product every year on defense.
Nineteen seventy-nine, we spent less than
5% of our gross national product on defense,
and during that same period of time while
we were reducing our overall percentage of
GNP on defense, we went roughly from two dollars
out of every four in the federal budget for
defense, to $1 out of every four, roughly,
for defense.
Simultaneously with that, we diverted resources
into the domestic area.
We adopted the Great Society programs, added
the disability program to Social Security.
I looked up the numbers the other day on the
disability program.
When it was set up in 1956, they estimated
that by 1980 there would be 1 million people
eligible for benefits and it would cost $860
million a year.
The reality in 1980 was that it didn't cost
860 million, it cost $17 billion and there
were 5 million people involved instead of
1.
There's been an enormous growth in the domestic
side, and I think obviously what you're talking
about is a reallocation of those resources,
not to the extent that we're gonna cut back
below the level we're already spending in
an area.
But that future growth in the budget is going
to have to come in the defense area, while
simultaneously we put the brakes to the increased
spending in the non-defense area.
And obviously, you're gonna have to address
I think some of the entitlement programs.
John: Representative Gingrich?
Representative Gingrich: John, I, if I can,
comment on one of the premises of your question.
I'm not certain, despite all the rhetoric,
that we need to spend dramatically more on
defense, although I'm a hawk in most ways.
I am certain that we need to spend our money
differently on defense.
And I think one of the places that the president
ought to be looking at to change the budget
rather than cut it is inside the Pentagon.
I think that there is incredible amount of
waste and lack of effective management in
the military.
And I think that we have a set of assumptions
strategically that are nonsense in the present
age, and that we could completely rethink
the way we're doing things.
And I have a grave fear that we're going to
in effect spend let's say 8% of GNP instead
of 5%, feel that we are thereby more safe,
and in fact build a Maginot Line behind which
we accomplish nothing.
I don't see right now any automatic increased
security for America by blindly throwing money
into the Pentagon and hoping that that scares
the Russians.
Now I think on managing the budget, which
is a different issue, that Ronald Reagan would
do well to study the career of Gladstone,
who spent 40 years being a pinchpenny in Britain,
and convinced the entire middle class that
he looked after their dollars, and that if
he didn't have to spend them in the government
he gave them back to them, so they could spend
them on their own families.
I think you start frankly with massive decentralization.
You take virtually every government grant
program, you lump it into five or six categorical
programs, and you give all that money back
and in a...rather in a block grant, not category.
You give all that money back to the state
of Georgia, and you say to the state legislature,
"Figure out how to spend, you know, what we
used to give you in 27 different grants,"
and you eliminate, in this city, I mean, you
have a real estate depression in Washington,
because you shift the bureaucracy out of Washington
and the decision-making out of Washington
back into state and local government.
I think that alone would probably save us
literally something on the order of $10 to
$20 billion in an annual budget.
John: We'd like to hear from the other side
of Georgia.
Representative Fowler: Well, John, first of
all, we have got to in this country come up
with a redefinition of defense.
I mean, defense is just not more and more
missiles and more and more technological systems.
Defense is getting off a $90 billion heroin-like
habit on imported energy, which is threatening
our national security because of our profligation
in energy use and its relationship to the
rest of the world.
Defense is making...Defense is taking some
real risk in foreign policy, that we have
had problems in the Congress reaching any,
even the beginnings of consensus either within
our party or in league with the Republicans.
I mean when Robert Mugabe, who campaigns as
a Marxist then comes to Washington and says,
"Look, we have a freely elected government
in Zimbabwe.
We don't want the Russians in there, but we
need your help to the tune of $35, $45 million,
not billion, million, to try to help us keep
the Russians out.
We don't want them.
They just take over your country.
We want to follow your westernized trends."
And we shut the door, same in Nicaragua.
Nobody knows whether or not they're going
to go running to the Russians one year, or
two years, or two weeks later.
But the point is you've got to take some risk
around the world to make some friends that
will be your allies in difficult times.
We can't...we could spend until the cows come
home, and we could not field an army on the
Soviet border to protect either Afghanistan
or Poland in my opinion.
We could spend till the cows come home with
all sorts of new technological systems.
And if we had to draw the line in the Horn
of Africa either in and around Ethiopia, Somalia,
Djibouti, we could not do it.
Because we look at defense spending only in
terms of new Trident submarines, and MX and
all the technological gadgets, and ignore
the rest of the world who are rapidly choosing
sides to say, "We either want to be on the
side of the United States because they're
our friend, or we like to go over to the Soviets
because they help us when we need help."
John: In this whole area of foreign policy,
which I'm glad you raised, and public policy,
do you see a new direction and perhaps a more
effective and efficient use of public policy
in the field of foreign affairs in the reaction
to Afghanistan and the Polish crises in 1980?
I.e.
an almost acceptance that we are militarily
incapable of acting, but that we will organize
such economic punishment and public relations
punishment that we could perhaps stop the
Soviet ambitions?
Do you find this a new approach, an effective
approach Mr. Gingrich?
Representative Gingrich: John, you've covered
a lot of this over the years.
And there has always been despite the occasional
headlines an American assumption, that we
had neither the interest, the desire, nor
the will to exert military power within reach
of the Soviet border.
We never under Eisenhower, Kennedy, anyone
thought that we could help Poland.
Franklin Roosevelt didn't think we could help
Poland, and basically made a deal.
And that's always been our policy, that Poland
will be as free as the Soviet Union allows
it to be.
We have no interest in Afghanistan at the
present time, have never had any.
And I think that you have to look very carefully
at what we want to accomplish with our policy.
We have defended Europe very ably I think
and very cheaply for 35 years now.
On the assumption that if you keep a large
enough garrison army there, and enough dependents
there, that a Soviet invasion of Europe means
nuclear war and that there are no risks they'll
take leading to nuclear war in Europe.
We've defended Japan under exactly the same
premise, and then on occasion, we have stumbled
into various and sundry secondary wars.
Vietnam being the least admirable example
both in efficiency and maybe in wisdom.
I think we have to think through our policies,
and we're, you know, we're currently not doing
that.
What has happened in the last two years, is
the largest swing in public opinion since
1939.
What we have seen is a general view, I think
not that we're inferior per se, but that military
force makes a difference.
And I think in that sense the invasion of
Afghanistan, the Iranian crisis, which I think
had much more to do with our nationalism right
now than Afghanistan, and finally Poland,
do mean that there's a broad public feeling
that the world is dangerous, and we have to
be capable of surviving in it.
I think that's where we're at.
John: Representative Gephardt?
Representative Gephardt: Well, I think the
actions taken by the president with regard
to the Soviet Union after Afghanistan were
a departure in public policy, to some extent
from what we've done in the past.
It was an exertion of linkage if you will
in the Soviet relationship.
It was an attempt to treat their bad behavior
with punishment.
I think it had an effect.
Will it stop them from going into Poland?
Probably not, but did it have an effect?
I think it did and I think it was a constructive
effect.
And I think we all however agree that having
sufficient military power as one of our foreign
policy tools is absolutely necessary, and
that since Vietnam, whether we like it or
not, we've allowed that military machine to
fall into a certain state of disrepair, which
has to be remedied.
John: All right, I think that we have opened
up this whole issue of the possibilities of
future.
We've certainly decided the possibilities
for revitalizing America are numerous, but
that the achievement of the goals is going
to be a hard road, and it's time for us to
have a question-and-answer session.
May I have the first question please?
Howard: I'm Howard Pennyman.
I'm from American Enterprise Institute in
Georgetown University.
Could I go back to some of the very early
discussion?
The question of whether people represent their
district or represent the United States is
an old question.
Woodrow Wilson said as far as a century ago
that American congressman represented their
district and not the nation as a whole.
Every basic reform, whether it be to change
the electoral system or to reform the Congress
has tended to further fragment and decentralize
the Congress.
One of the results is, it seems to me, and
I'd like to ask all of you to comment on it,
is that it has so made congressman represent
their districts that they both A, believe
deeply in cutting the budget, and B in never
cutting it where it would hurt anybody among
those who have interests in their districts.
John: Right, who would like to start with
that?
You look like a good, bold, brave...To Cheney.
Representative Cheney: I think most of us
attempt to achieve some kind of balance.
I mean after you've campaigned for a year
or two years or in the case of Mr. Gingrich
from Georgia, three separate times before
you win, you feel that you have a common identity
with your constituents.
And I think most members probably when it
comes time to cast a vote on a key issue,
rarely feel a tug between, on the one hand,
so-called national interest and on the other
hand, district interest.
You've rationalized in your own mind that
what your constituents want and what you want
is what's right for the country.
It's those fellows on the other side that
are representing the special interest in their
districts, so that the choice in the mind
of the congressman I think is really framed
in those clear-cut terms.
Representative Gephardt: I think your attitude
toward voting is in large part dependent upon
your last majority.
If you won by 50.00001%, I think you keep
your ear pretty close to the ground in preparation
for the next campaign.
If you won by 95% of the vote, I think you
vote fairly freely according to the dictates
of your conscience, whether that be in line
with your district, and what it thinks and
what the majority thinks, or what would be
seen as a national position.
Howard: [inaudible 00:41:27] congressman Cheney's
position about giving authority to the President
to carry out the cuts which you talk about.
Representative Gingrich: Let me make a comment,
because it...I don't know...Political science
has done an enormous disservice to government
in this country, because it is almost completely
ahistorical.
The founding fathers deliberately designed
one branch of the government to be permanently
scared, and that's why they have them run
every two years.
It is a deliberate design function.
They specifically want us to speak for the
district, and they have the rather naive belief
that if a president can't find 218 districts
that gain more than they lose from a particular
bill, that that bill ought to be defeated.
Now I think by George, you're supposed to
speak for the people of your district, because
that's who you understand, that's who you
represent, and that you collectively, as The
House, represent the country.
And I think any congressman who gets up and
says, "Well, this will destroy my district
economically, but in the national interest
I want to do that," is in fact betraying their
specific commitment in the Constitution.
And I find it very frankly naive and destructive
in the long run to keep favoring a general
good which has no specific good, because I
don't think there is a general good for the
country as a whole, which you can't piece
together in 218 districts.
Representative Cheney: But Newt wouldn't you
agree then on that basis, and I think this
goes back to the question that was asked,
that given the constitutional arrangement,
given our mandate as congressmen to represent
our districts, that in looking for that spark,
that dynamic spark or leadership or initiative
that is going to set the agenda and help solve
the problems, we have to look to the presidency.
That that is more likely to be the arena in
which the answers are found than in the Congress.
Representative Gingrich: It is specifically
and precisely in the Federalist Papers and
in almost all the writing of the founding
fathers, a concern that we have effective
leadership in the Congress, because it is
among the congressmen that you should make
the compromises and the understandings and
the level of political sophistication necessary
both to manage the people who we pay, the
bureaucrats, and to rearrange the legislation
for our constituents.
And it is the failure of our generation to
produce effective political and congressional
leaders in the Congress that leads us I think
to the very grave danger in the long run of
tyranny.
John: We would be most interested to hear
from you, Mr. Fowler.
Representative Fowler: Thank you Mr. Speaker.
Well, I think it may be naive and I will admit
to that.
But to respond to Mr. Gingrich.
What we need in the United States Congress
are men and women who are not afraid to lose.
Who do not see this as a lifelong profession
to service a constituency so readily, and
only that constituency in every little whim
of public policy that the breeze may blow,
to simply perpetuate them in office.
Now I know that it's a lot easier to say than
to do, if they're going to close a military
base in your district, to build a more modern
one somewhere else.
That is in the national interest to do so.
It is not in the economic interest of that
member's district.
That's when you earn your pay.
To vote to close it in your district in order
to achieve the national interest to modernize
your defense establishment.
I mean these questions have been debated,
but we are not, 535 men and women, are not
city councilmen.
We're not state legislators.
We shouldn't be ward politicians catering
to whatever sense of information and purpose
that comes on a weekly basis, or you will
never mold any national policy.
But the problem is that we won't stay here.
So most of us are afraid to vote on any given
issue in something that's too brave, because
then we get thrown out next time.
Representative Gephardt: Can I go back on
it?
I think the question is perhaps not as well
put as it could be.
Most issues don't break down very neatly,
as I think Dick said, into a district interest
and a national interest.
It breaks down between what you perceive as
being both in the interest of your district
and the national interest, and an interest
group that is usually represented in your
constituency.
Let's take the example of the twice a year
COLA for federal retirees, the cost of living
adjustment.
I think most members probably felt that that
was a change.
Making it a once a year cost of living adjustment
was a change that was in order, that was legitimate
and appropriate.
But each of us had 3 or 5 or 6,000 federal
retirees sitting in our district, writing
letters, making telephone calls.
And so people, a lot of people before an election,
did not want to vote against that large group,
when you're winning by 1,000 or 3,000 or 6,000
votes.
That to me is the way a lot of issues are
presented, and I don't think it breaks down
as neatly as perhaps your question suggests.
John: The next question please.
Yes sir?
John H.: I'm John Hellman [SP], I'm from the
University of Washington in Seattle, and AEI.
And I, relaying a question as chairman of
a Department of Political Science from my
students.
Because I've been quite amazed to hear four
congressmen talk about revitalizing America
without directly addressing a question of
revitalizing Congress.
The mood, if I may repeat my students, is
that Washington is a subculture, that congressmen
do not act as statesmen, they simply represent
those interests that have access to them,
be they local constituents or Washington interest
groups.
They rarely transcend the immediate.
They do not provide a basis for leadership
for the country.
I call to your attention also repeated public
opinion polls expressing approval which rarely
exceeds 30% of the performance of the role
of Congress, and one taken in the early, I
guess, about 1974, where congressmen were
rated above trash collectors and below barbers
in terms of professional respect.
I would like to raise the question to all
of you.
What is wrong?
And do you think anything can be done to alter
the image of Congress?
Because the perception out there is not that
you are doing a superb job, but that somehow
you are doing a job that must be done but
not doing it very well.
John: Mr. Fowler has volunteered.
Representative Fowler: Well, let me let me
wade in where angels fear to tread for your
students, to say that first I would say to
your students that in a free society, in a
representative system, that you get the kind
of government that you deserve.
If you tolerate apathy in your public officials,
you get apathy.
If you tolerate corruption, then you get corruption.
Because we are still a government by the governed,
by those students and the people in this room
and people throughout the country.
The Congress will never be any greater in
its statesmanship than the values and the
hopes and the demands of the American people.
We have the same faults, they are certain
because we are representative, and come from
a system where we are elected every two years.
We mirror those hopes and those aspirations,
and those faults.
That means you get a certain number of blue-eyed
people.
You get a certain number of alcoholics.
You get a certain number of any other trend
that you want to put on your computer.
But back to the question that we discussed
before, the real question is in a pluralistic
society, where you've got black people and
Spaniards and rich people and poor people.
How on any given vote can you be truly representative?
I represent a district that's 50% black and
50% white.
A district where the gap between the number
of high-income people and number of low-income
people, that gap in between is greater than
any other congressional district in the country
according to all these computer operators.
So the question that I would ask to your students
is how can you be on any given vote truly
representative?
You can't.
I know that on any given vote, I'm not going
to make 50% of them mad, but probably 80%
of them mad, when I cast a vote that I deem
to be in the national interest.
But you have to turn this question back in
a free society, to the people who are the
electorate, because they are the government
in this country.
And again, they're going to get what they
deserve in their representatives in Washington.
Representative Cheney: I think that the Congress
itself has to bear a great deal of the blame
for the way government's perceived, because
we probably do as much communicating as anybody
in America today next to Walter Cronkite and
the people on the evening news shows.
We send out newsletters.
We make speeches.
We visit with our constituents.
To the extent that the American people have
a perspective on government, I think to some
extent we're responsible for having created
that.
We create it by castigating the courts, and
condemning the bureaucracy, and worrying about
alleged abuses of presidential power by presidents.
And we also I think have failed in the very
important perspective of being reflective
about what our role and our responsibility
is.
Yes, we do have to be representative.
Yes, we do have to pass appropriations bills
and conduct oversight.
But we don't debate the great issues of the
day.
We spend hours and hours and hours on absolutely
idiotic procedural questions.
We don't get into the basic fundamental issues
that I think the American people often feel
ought to be the central concern of their government,
and to some extent we brought it on ourselves.
Representative Gephardt: I think your students
are probably basically right.
I think that there are two instances or two
conditions which will change the condition
of Congress.
One is if more of your students will take
it upon themselves to run for Congress, rather
than going into the business world to make
a big buck.
Or secondly if we have a catastrophe in the
country and people really begin to worry about
what Congress is doing.
As Dick said, 95% of us get reelected.
If we're not exerting leadership, then the
American people don't want leadership, because
they're reelecting people that your students
say are not giving them leadership.
I think as long as things were going along
relatively well, and they have been for 40
or 50 years up until about the last 10, nobody
really cared.
Representative Gingrich: [inaudible 00:52:45]
both of you, because you're both Democrats
and just went through a tough election in
terms of your party at large.
It seems to me that one of our great problems
is that each of us is individually perceived
as a very effective representative.
That the problem is that Congress in the aggregate
is not able to function in, it's an anti-synergism,
whatever that word is.
That we bring together each of the 435 parts
and we somehow become less than the sum of
the whole.
And I think that's been one of our great problems.
We're all much better as individuals than
we are as a team.
Representative Fowler: You know, I was running
around in my district and I looked at this
high school that I used to go to, a public
high school.
I couldn't figure out how it was different.
It looked different.
I could tell, but I couldn't...it took me
20 minutes of looking at it.
And all of a sudden I realized that it was
this one tremendous parking lot around it.
We didn't have cars 20 years ago when I went
to high school.
Now everybody's got their own car.
So when your students start worrying about
whether or not, why we don't have an effective
energy policy in this country, ask them how
many of them would be willing to be statesmen,
and give up those cars until we got our imported
oil bill down from $90 billion a year to $10
billion a year?
And we'll test statesmanship at both ends.
Representative Gephardt: But Wyche, I sense
that your students are asking for tough leadership
decisions, like a gas tax.
John Anderson was very popular on college
campuses.
He talked about tough solutions to tough problems.
And I think what you're saying is that that's
what they're asking for.
And I would just suggest back that that will
happen when either we have a catastrophe,
and then people demand those kinds of things
happen, are willing to have a consensus form
in that regard.
Or until we get 219 people in the house and
51 people in the Senate who perceive that
that kind of thing, I'm not saying that's
necessarily a right policy, but those kinds
of things are necessary to do.
Representative Fowler: You should go ahead
and endorse my policy.
Representative Gephardt: I'm for the gas tax.
I voted for it.
John H.: One final remark.
The students want to believe.
I think that is an interesting point.
Enrollments in political science are up 50%,
60% over the last two years.
And the interest in governance and governmental
institutions is truly growing.
And Anderson's appeal was very substantial
around altruistic symbols.
I think the complaint about Congress is they
don't find inspiration, they don't find something
there that they can look to as more than a
mirror of the society.
Maybe it can't be more than that but that's
somehow what they want.
John: Anybody else wants to talk to this?
Representative Gingrich: [inaudible 00:55:44]
thought.
What if in fact the reason we are floundering
around in the Congress is because the country
is floundering around?
What if in fact it is the nature of a free
society to take long periods to talk to itself,
to sort things out, to move slowly so as not
to crush any single group, and that one of
the things that our students are going to
have to learn in the long run is that to be
free there's on occasion to be impatient,
to be frustrated and have to work awfully
hard to get anything done, because that is
in fact precisely what freedom takes.
I think in that sense, if you look at our
record compared to Nazi Germany or compared
to Soviet Russia, we don't do all that bad
a job over 20 years, although certainly we
do a terrible job over 1 year.
John: All right, this concludes another public
policy forum presented by the American Enterprise
Institute for Public Policy Research.
On behalf of AEI, our hearty thanks to the
distinguished and expert panelists, Congressmen
Newt Gingrich, Richard B. Cheney, Richard
Gephardt, and Wyche Fowler, and of course,
also to our guests and experts in the audience
for their participation.
Announcer: It is the aim of AEI to clarify
issues of the day by presenting many viewpoints,
in the hope that by doing so, those who wish
to learn about the decision-making process
will benefit from such a free exchange of
informed and enlightened opinion.
This public policy forum series is created
and supplied to this station as a public service
by the American Enterprise Institute, Washington
D.C.
AEI is a nonprofit, nonpartisan, publicly
supported research and education organization.
Information on this and other subject areas,
including government regulation, economic
policy, Social Security and retirement, health
policy, legal policy, tax policy, political
and social processes, energy policy, defense
policy and international affairs is available
from the Institute.
For a transcript of this program, send $3.75
to the American Enterprise Institute, 1150
17th Street Northwest, Washington, D.C. 20036.